[Music]
it's true the US military is a costly
enterprise it cost us more as a share of
our total output during the Cold War but
in absolute dollar terms we're spending
about as much now as we spent during the
Cold War so the cost to maintain primacy
has remained relatively high and the
question is could we spend much more on
the military to cover some of the gaps
between what we asked our military to do
and the resources they have to carry out
those missions I think the answer is we
could spend more but it's not in our
interest to do so just spending more on
the military won't ensure that the
military for example will be able to
succeed in some of the conflicts that it
hasn't yet achieved decisive victory I
think it actually speaks to the limits
of military power that you can spend a
lot and you can have the most exquisite
military in the world which we
absolutely do and yet that same military
struggles to defeat determined
adversaries wielding crude weapons in
places like Iraq or Syria or Afghanistan
and I think that really does speak that
that just spending more money on the
problem is not likely to solve the
problem it is likely to encourage us to
get more deeply involved in some
conflicts that might genuinely be
intractable and that ultimately aren't
vital to you u.s. national security for
our country is powerful as the United
States and especially a country with
with global interests and with a large
and capable military it's really
important to define ahead of time when
that military will be used I use some
basic criteria they're consistent with
things like the Weinberger Powell
doctrine from the Cold War an early cold
post Cold War period things like what's
the national security interest at stake
what are we asking our military to do
will the public support the mission even
if the mission gets difficult and costly
related how are we going to pay for it
will the war be paid for by for example
a war tax or will we
pay for it through debt like we did in
World War two those sorts of questions
are important to ask before we send our
military into harm's way and I think
that's an again the nature of the US
military because it exists and it is so
large and strong and in many places
simultaneously it's fairly easy for that
military to become involved in conflicts
before we ask any of those questions and
so I think it's really important for the
American people and for American
policymakers to keep in mind some basic
criteria for when we use force the last
point I'd make is that you know war is a
perilous enterprise it involves the
threat of violence and the destruction
of property and therefore we shouldn't
enter into it lightly and so I think
when I think of restraint and an
instinct of non-intervention it's more
about just a sort of skeptical eye it's
a sort of hesitant to use force
that doesn't mean never using force it
means thinking through it very very
carefully before we do one of the great
disservice --is we do to the military is
to expect the American people to support
it at all costs for any reason and not
expecting the American people to
actually scrutinize the missions that we
ask the military to do in other words
the greatest service that we can do to
our veterans is to make sure that there
are relatively few of them those who are
who do go to war in defense of vital US
national security interests are doing so
for the right set of reasons it would
almost be unpatriotic it seems to me for
Americans to not think carefully about
the wars that we ask our military to
fight most of us the vast majority of us
will have never served in the military
and the few of us who have I think
understand just what an important
undertaking it is and and this country
is is quite accustomed to going to war
without much debate and I think that
really is a disservice to the military
into the those who serve a key component
of primacy is to reassure our allies and
we
do that for the most part to discourage
them from taking measures to defend
themselves this might sound a little
strange but it actually made some sense
after World War two when these countries
were badly broken by World War two and
endangered by the Soviet Union in Europe
these countries were in no position to
defend themselves they were they had to
focus on rebuilding themselves
rebuilding themselves physically and
also rebuilding themselves politically
so the notion of reassurance as a as a
means to discourage countries from doing
more to defend themselves made certain
sense at that time the challenge however
is that these countries have become
quite stable and secure and yet we never
really revisited the bargain and so we
continue to have free-riding behavior or
cheap writing behavior countries not
paying what they might need to pay in
order to defend themselves the other
problem with having too much reassurance
is it can lead to moral hazard it can
lead to reckless driving
that is if allies believe that the
United States has their back no matter
what they might be inclined to behave in
reckless ways they might be inclined to
to take actions that they wouldn't if
they were carrying the full burden and
the and the risks they might simply be
discouraged from undertaking reasonable
compromises on behalf of maintaining
peace with their neighbors or in their
region and so this the the danger is
that primacy encourages a kind of
reckless behavior that ultimately is not
conducive to long term peace when the
United States became the first nuclear
weapons state there was some fear that
many other countries would follow the
Soviet Union did a few other countries
did Britain and France but by the late
1950s early 1960s a pretty concerted
effort to discourage other countries
from going that route the fear was that
if many countries had nuclear weapons
then the chances of their use would
dramatically increase and a key part of
reassurance is to discourage
particularly US allies like Germany and
Japan from ever being tempted to develop
nuclear weapons in fact I think in many
respects that is one of
a key arguments that defenders of
primacy make is that were not for
primacy there would be much much more
nuclear proliferation than there has
been I think it's also true however that
primacy has encouraged some countries
that are left out of the system the
so-called rogue states to want to
develop nuclear weapons of their own to
deter the United States from attacking
them we've seen that in places like
North Korea which is one of the poorest
countries on the planet but it's
nonetheless managed to develop a nuclear
weapon or the fear that places like Iran
might want a nuclear weapon for
precisely that same reason and so I
think it's fair to say that while the
u.s. primacy probably has discouraged
some of our friends from developing
nuclear weapons it has done sort of a
has sort of a mixed track record of
discouraging our adversaries or
potential adversaries from wanting
nuclear weapon with the United States so
heavily dependent upon military power as
its main instrument of engagement the
rest of the world it's somewhat
inevitable that the State Department and
traditional diplomacy is sort of
relegated to the back seat or to no seat
at all and I think we've certainly seen
that happen over the course the last 15
or 20 years where the military receives
the lion's share of resources that go to
engagement and when the United States is
asked or expected to interact with
others it usually comes from people who
are at least if not carrying a weapon
themselves at least backed by people who
are of course that's not the way the
United States has always interacted with
the rest of the world traditional
diplomacy is gone both from the State
Department and our actual official
diplomats but has also been carried by
business people and NGOs and and private
actors who interact with the rest of the
world and so I think one of the great
dangers of primacy is that because it is
defined so much in military terms it
means inevitably that diplomacy is sort
of given short shrift
[Music]